et bakou où est ce que je vous emmène à
la fin du monde à quelque chose près
aujourd'hui on va se tester quoi on va
se tester ça ça c'est quoi ça c'est un
samsung oui il ya un crocodile mais non
c'est pas pour conduire aux tests c'est
un samsung galaxy s 22 ultra qu'est-ce
qu'on fait que samsung galaxy s 22 ultra
on va se tester le mode nuit c'est quoi
c'est la nato graphie la photo de nuit
en gros la photo et la vidéo nuit donc
on va shooter une nuit on commença à
faire des images on a déjà vu des
chasses mais on va pas s'arrêter là
pourquoi parce qu'on est dégueu d'un et
on fait quoi on va ici on va se bat lyon
fait de l'urbex wes aujourd'hui une
vidéo qui est réalisé en partenariat
avec samsung pour aller découvrir lui là
ce qui fait la nuit et aujourd'hui on
fait pas tout seul on est avec julie
ferhat bien là julie joho l'algérie elle
et je me baisse est jolie mais aussi à
scott scott et son petit chien levrat il
est caché les parlé à beaucoup scott
alors julie toi tu écris un trait sur
les réseaux tic
tard exactement c'est une star des
réseaux et aujourd'hui je voyais d'une
star des réseaux et puis on va à lyon
vexé ensemble a aussi toi tu as 22 plus
exactement voilà c'est ça elles vendent
de plus cette zone de letra ont fait de
leur mexes et puis on va essayer de
finir envie de rester ensemble donc on y
va c'est parti
[Musique]
oriali casier il ya des casiers regardez
je
sais comme ça qu'elle fois qu'il te
casses mai
[Musique]
là on est calme dans un spot un peu un
peu très nature côtoie alors il faut
quand même un poil de lumière on peut
shooter la nuit mais il faut quand même
un poil de lumière
[Musique]
alors est-ce que je suis pas choses à
l'endroit où le toit s'effondre c'est de
l'urbex ont fait de l'urbex pourquoi
pour venir tester les photos de nuit et
les vidéos de nuit avec le nouveau
samsung galaxy s 22 ultra
[Musique]
celle affichée à l'écran parce que la
lgo est quand même assez loin en terme
de correction en jouant au début contre
eux sans l'écran c'est un peu sombre et
lorsque ça finit de le sortir c'est
vraiment tragique place à l'espèce de
yéti mais c'est vrai que malgré tout on
y voit quand même ça c'est plutôt cool
une pause pour une pause en avoir encore
un chien
[Musique]
paf de retour ici au studio alors on a
fini hier soir ce petit sur bex petite
balade sympa avec lui là le samsung
galaxy s 22 ultra et je vais vous
montrer les fentes or pour vous montrer
les photos qu'est ce qu'on va faire
rentrer une tablette celle là la
nouvelle samsung galaxy tab est ultra
jeudi vita parce qu'il ya tellement de
mots qu'il ya tellement de lettres qu'il
faut y aller un petit peu vite alors
regardez elle est là elle est belle elle
est tout en en forme alors ce qu'on va
faire dans cette partie de la vidéo on
va regarder les photos qui ont été
prises hier soir on va regarder les
vidéos d'abord les photos ensuite les
vidéos puis à trois moments différents
je dirais aux tombées de la nuit
lorsqu'il ya encore de la lumière
suffisamment de lumière ou le smartphone
ne va pas chercher à fond dans ses
ressources pour venir vous sortir des
photos d'une nuit de bonne qualité très
bonne qualité mais il n'a pas à tartiner
comme un fou pour y arriver on vend
c'est dans une zone de pénombre quand ça
commence vraiment arrivé et puis on
finira la nuit noire pour voir s'ils
s'en sort aussi bien aux photos aussi
bien au niveau de la vidéo et vous allez
voir que c'est intéressant première
chose on va lancer un petit
enregistrement l'écran mais parce qu'on
a quand même besoin de savoir ce qu'on
fait c'est quand même plutôt pratique
allez on y va alors regardez j'ai un
autre truc là espen espagne pour venir
bosser en même temps alors on va
regarder d'abord toutes ces photos la
neva on va dans la galerie là on
commence avec des photos en fait que
j'ai prises tout au début on voit
effectivement que ça marche ça c'est sûr
le grand-angle on voit que le résultat
est vraiment bon alors on peut venir
nous met un peu si on veut mais on a la
lumière extérieure la nuit commence tout
doucement arrivé on se rend pas
forcément compte mais on est vraiment
sûr soleil qui baissent un look simple
un petit peu rageant on est moment un
peu de la golden hour si vous voulez
donc fatalement et bien
ça fonctionne et ça me paraît assez
normal hop là on continue la gv nu ou
mais un petit peu histoire de vous
montrer le téléobjectif ici vous savez
alors je vous renvoie à ma vidéo de
présentation du samsung galaxy s 22
ultra pour revoir la config photo comme
ça vous saurez tout on peut venir nous
mais là pas de souci ça fait le taff
élus ultra grand-angle avec la lumière
que vous avez là tout de suite ça
fonctionne pas de souci ça c'est une
photo que julie a pris le mois merci
julie très sympathique on continue je
trouve cette phrase un petit peu
rigolote donc c'est pour ça que je
voulais mise il faut être unique mais
rentrer dans une case toute cette voie
là on peut faire défiler aujourd'hui
alors ça c'est des faux vidéo les vidéos
je voulais montrerait plus tard on
continue toujours dans cette même
c'était moment en fait si vous voulez un
petit peu de tombée de la nuit mais pour
niveau de la pénombre ça fonctionne
c'est vraiment bien alors après ce qu'on
peut bien faire du trac vente en voyant
dans la lune et là on est ensuite sur le
zoom ce qu'on peut venir faire ici c'est
venir larbaud c'est un petit peu sous
sous lightroom pourquoi tout simplement
parce que je la trouve bien mais je
pense qu'on peut venir les rajouter un
petit peu dynamique alors attendez
j'avais bossé là dessus tac tac tac tac
et j'en ai fait quelques unes de vos
lions s'est bien amusé elle est là elle
est là alors je trouve une fois de plus
très très cool mais regardez là
j'aimerais bien venir mois déjà la
saturer un poil plus voit l'avenir la
ceinture un peu alors après c'est normal
la lumière baisse donc je suis pas sûr
du rhône donc j'ai pas shooter enr
hostilités sur dur aux sas à cagnes plus
évident on peut baisser un peu la
température de couleur et on peut venir
rajouter voyez c'est truc assez sympa
pour venir bosser là avoir ajouté un peu
de texture on voit un peu mieux les
briques mais c'est pas mal voyez déjà là
on a un truc est quand même plutôt bien
attention niveau des hautes lumières on
peut venir jouer un petit peu sur la
lumière ici y en a pas des masses et on
vient contraster légèrement dit
légèrement alors comme je suis pas sûr
du rouge peut y aller un peu plus franc
dévié mais regardez l'avant après ça
c'est après avant voyez il ya quand même
un vrai gamin donc on peut venir c'est
un peu saturé agi seul un peu fort sur
la saturation mais voyez il ya un truc
intéressant au niveau du combo dont je
vais vous le montrer effectivement avec
d'un côté votre table et suite ultra et
de l'autre côté votre galaxy s ii ultra
donc ça voyait à la tombée de la nuit ça
fonctionne dans les choses qui sont qui
sont vraiment vraiment sympa toujours
pareil là c'était alors j'ai tenté les
deux petites photos ça bouge et c'est
pour ça que c'est un peu moins ou photo
avec elle ne fait rien
donc ça c'est bon ça roule photo à
l'intérieur aussi j'aimais bien ce côté
voyais très urbain très urbain hex avec
josh pas citer les vieilles prises 1 je
pense mais alors pour tout vous dire on
a fait le break dans un ancien abattoir
salvateur de porcs qui fatalement
n'existe plus aujourd'hui et j'aime bien
la cie photos que ça va vous sortir
voyez un peu ce côté rouillé j'adore ça
vachement vachement cool ok donc ça
c'est pour vous montrer alors là on est
dans des photos un endroit où il y avait
déjà beaucoup moins de lumière on voit
qu'il ya eu un petit peu de mouvements
ici c'est pour ça que julie un peu flou
mais tout le reste est extrêmement
nettes donc là on arrive dans une zone
jeudi à un peu plus de pénombre dans la
pénombre une fois de plus s'en sort
vachement bien regardez là là c'est
vraiment très très sombre il faut
imaginer que là ce que vous voyez ça
paraît clair on voit bien mais lorsque
je viens moi avec mes yeux je vous
assure que je vois pas aussi bien et que
du coup c'est pour sa convenance ou mais
on perd le détail sur le visage de julie
parce que il fait quand même très très
sombre mais lorsque vous êtes comme ça
ça fonctionne et ça fonctionne même très
bien alors on peut venir rouler un peu
et je vais vous montrer parce que pareil
toujours dans la même zone de pénombre
on le voit on arrive à voir vachement
donc sasaki vachement intéressant si
vous regardez j'avais posé sur un pied
donc j'ai une expo l'ont forcément ça
vient de récupérer et bien beaucoup de
choses ça vient me compensés beaucoup de
choses il ya un algorithme qui est
derrière ça veut dire que comme ça on
l'expliqué très longue si vous voulez y
laisse rentrer beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus de l'ermite de
lumière et après vous avez tous les
traitements ego rythmique qui vient peut
sauver l'histoire on a fait des photos
d'époque avec julie alors je trouve que
nous on pose mon doivent bouger un petit
peu ce qui fait que c'est un peu moins
précis voyez au niveau des visages ici
mais n'oublions pas qu'on est sur des
photos nuit dont je suis fait pour le
résultat est vraiment très très très
très bluffant toujours dans l'idée de la
pénombre à l'extérieur ça marche bien
mais il faut pas du tout bougé envoyé
dès qu'on bouge on le voit tout de suite
on perd un petit peu en netteté c'est
très crépusculaire mais pour autant ça
marche bien et là pour le coup ça
vraiment bien bossé un haut niveau de
son visage au niveau des formes ça
marche bien toujours dans cette zone de
pénombre c'était quand même très très
sombre à ce moment là on était encore en
extérieur on a des choses qui sont
vraiment très très très jolie un cheveu
du zoom et voyez on a plein de détails
ont des couleurs c'est saturé ça marche
bien alors l'ultra grand temps commence
à avoir un peu plus de mal là on le voit
on perd un peu en précision c'est un
poil désaturer c'est plus bruitées mais
les ultra grand-angle et les photos nuit
ça fait 2 donc ça ça me paraît normal
mais voyez sur le capteur principal on
sort des choses qui sont très sympas et
là on a fait un paquet et je trouve que
vraiment ça fonctionne mais une fois de
plus ce pas bougé et dès qu'on prend la
pose et que ça bouge pas et ben on sort
des choses vraiment rigolote et une fois
de plus c'est pareil le mode là
fonctionne bien alors toujours pareil ça
c'est à la paix non on se rend pas
compte qu'on voit le ciel bleu mais en
fait c'est parce que c'est une pause
longue pause est sur un pied ça vous
sorte de super truc on est en extérieur
et maintenant on va se mettre alors
toujours en extérieur lâcher quelques
petites photos du téléphone qui est et
maintenant on va se mettre en intérieur
et là en intérieur c'est lui la nuit
noire on n'y voit rien très honnêtement
on n'y voit rien truc de dingue donc la
voyez photos de nuit on n'y voit rien
c'est quasiment la nuit ici donc on
livre rien attention on prend note
souffre je pars le seuil d'un résultat
est pas menthe à tronche c'est ouf et en
fait ça te le fais avec plein de photos
comme ça alors qu'il fait vraiment nui
quoi et c'est juste bluffant c'est juste
de regarder ce qu'on sort c'est saturé
il ya du détail c'est net et on voit
comme des reflets de lumière là qui
viennent de l'extérieur parce que pour
autant je vous assure il n'y a pas de
flash il n'y a pas de lumière donc c'est
très très très très bluffant c'est vrai
qu'ils ont en l2 qui marche très bien
alors ça c'est pareil c'est une pause
très longue j'ai fait comme ça et j'ai
fait avec moi à la voyez donc vous en
train de poser avec mathieu il n'y a pas
de lumière c'est ça qui est dingue en
fait là je vous assure qu'on n'y voit
rien perdre et on a fait une capture
d'écran donc la regarder sur la capture
d'écran hop là je suis en train
d'arriver je prends la pause on voit un
côté sombre j'ai une pause longue de 30
secondes annoncé vachement long 30
secondes et à la fin on arrive à ça
voilà trente secondes alors j'ai un
petit peu bougé excusez moi sur 30
secondes ce qui fait qu'on a ce côté là
la voyait qui va être un peu moins net
sur le côté mais ces gars extrêmement
bluffant regardez c'est les mêmes
conditions prise tout petit peu avant
sur une expo longue et rendez vous
compte que il fait noir voilà il fait
vraiment noah on ne voit absolument rien
donc ça c'est aussi un très très très
beau boulot dans les mêmes conditions
j'ai pris cette photo là où on n'y voit
rien on va laisser deviner j'ai compris
ce mot-là qui avait plein de bombes de
graff et des canettes au sol sinon je
les voyais pas eu toutes ces bombes de
graff là qui alla et ben je les ai vues
uniquement regardant la photo après
parce que mon nom j'ai shooté je voyais
absolument rien pareil donc tout ça et
puis sur les deux ans j'ai pris ça alors
ça c'est pareil cette photo là on peut
dire ouais ça va il s'est quand même
jour c'est plutôt pas mal mais rendez
vous compte que ça en fait c'est ça
c'est à dire que moment où on veut y
ajouter la dea en a fait une vidéo de
vin quelques secondes là je suis en
train de me poser voyez là je suis là je
sais pas si vous voyez une
reconnaissance de mon visage qui est
juste là et là on a dix secondes d'expo
long je suis là et là encore il ya les
éclairages donc vous n'allez pas faire
mon encontre je suis là la voyais mon
visage là pas évident de se rendre
compte comme ça je sais une fois qu'on a
fini ça on arrive là dessus voilà alors
une fois de plus j'ai un poil bouger
c'est pour ça qu'on a ce côté un petit
peu flou parce qu'on est sûr de l'expo
longue il faut absolument pas bouger
mais regardez ça il fait nuit noire donc
l'armée dans les conditions nuit noire
en extérieur et vous voyez que même nuit
noire en extérieur le l'eau est juste
énorme et c'est extrêmement bluffant
alors il ya une petite limite après on
s'est mise dans d'autres endroits à
l'intérieur et on a continué à shooter
mails envoyés plus rien du tout vraiment
plus rien du tout il ya un espèce de
faux contre jour parce qu'elle ait pas
deux jours mais y avait toujours un peu
plus ce qu'il y avait de la lune à
l'extérieur qu'à l'intérieur donc il n'y
a plus rien qui sortait intérieur je
tenter d'y faire un truc mais il ya un
moment quand il fait vraiment noir noir
noir noir et qui a plus toute source de
lumière ça ne marche pas donc voyons si
on fait un petit récap 1 c'est ça qui
est vachement dingue c'est à dire que
lorsque vous avez dans les conditions à
la tombée de la nuit ça vous change des
choses qui sont extrêmement bien qu'on
pourrait venir effectivement modifié
après sur lightroom surtout si vous
chutez henrot voulons récupérer
davantage on est ensuite dans des zones
où je dirais la nuit commence à tomber
et on sent mal tous des choses qui sont
super bien hypers qui allient et
notamment pour publier sur les réseaux
c'est aussi pour faire des 4 par 3
d'affichage ça va être ça mais pour
mettre sur les réseaux il ya aucun
problème et puis lorsqu'il fait nuit
noire vous sortez des choses qui sont
juste bluffante et voilà c'est voilà
c'est dingue donc ça c'est pour cette
partie là il aura pris à la partie vidéo
alors en vidéo il ya un poil plus de mal
je suis venu en pénombre et on a dix ans
cette vidéo la savoie
faut juste pas tomber qu'en fait
maurepas tu tombes pas aller bien ces
tensions ont lâché c'est clair au sol
donc il ya ça c'est quand j'ai filmé
julie en train de marcher bon ok ça
fonctionne ya pas grand chose là dessus
pareil en intérieur on a ça vous voyez
déjà c'est beaucoup moins précis là un
peu plus de mal malgré tout et je le
voyais vraiment au niveau de mon écran
je voyais mieux à travers mon écran que
ce que je voyais dans la pièce
directement avec mes yeux c'est très
très très bluffant et ça marche vraiment
vraiment bien là c'est julie qui me
filme avec son s22 plus ça leur laisse
22 plus il est là le s-bahn de plus il
ira moins loin que le s bahn fera donc
en termes de photos de nuit on ira quand
même un poil moins loin et notamment au
niveau de la vidéo ici on n'a pas les
mêmes capteurs souvenez vous je vous
parlais tout à l'heure de ces photos là
et je vous disais laïcisé vraiment très
très très sombres et bien en fait ça ça
a été shootée au même moment que ça donc
voyez que c'était quand même très très
sombre et pour autant ça c'est filmé
avec le f-22 plus on y voyait pas grand
chose il ya plus de bruit donc le
smartphone a beaucoup plus de mal à tout
de suite en vidéo de nuit parce que eh
bien il ya du mic le bruit alors julie
s'amuse à venir nous mais il faut pas
faire ça en vidéo ça ne marche pas on
voit qu'il a tout de suite beaucoup de
mal pareil ça c'est des choses qui ont
été shootés aux smartphones raft avec la
caméra de celle fille sage nous et
shooter avec julie en extérieur je
trouvais que c'était assez marrant ça
fait ça c'est afin pour du travail sur
les réseaux ça fera le taf ça c'est
pareil c'est du contenu qui a ajouté
julie on voit qu'il ya du bruit on voit
que ça on perd vraiment en précision il
est bien meilleur en condition de nuit
en photo qu'en vidéo un très clairement
et puis ensuite on s'est aventuré dans
des zones beaucoup plus noir et la voix
y est bon d'être dans le côté un peu
pénombre noir il est tout de suite un
peu plus aux fraises donc voyez ce que
je voulais vous montrer c'est vachement
intéressant parce qu'on voit à quel
point terme de photos nues avec ça le
samsung galaxy s 22 ultra ils nous
sortent des choses qui sont très bonnes
jusque dans des conditions je dirais
vraiment noir il ya certains moments où
il va vraiment plus y arriver s'il ya
plus du tout de petites sources
extérieures qui permettent de compenser
d'avoir un petit quelque chose d'assez
des capteurs il lui faut un tout petit
peu plus rien même pas grand chose un
fils et ils y arrivent en vidéo il va
décrocher un peu plus haut donc si on
résume ce que je vous avais dit à la
tombée de la nuit en photos et en vidéos
il est bien même si la photo restera
toujours au dessus dans des conditions
de pénombre il va commencer vraiment a
peiné en vidéo mais en photo il sera bon
et dans les conditions de in war avec
toujours un petit filet lumière
attention tout petit filet lumière une
nuit l'extérieur voilà même pas une
pleine lune juste un petit filet lui
l'extérieur en photo il fera halte à
fleurs bien évidemment noire des photos
qui seront un peu plus dé saturer qu'on
pourra venir travailler derrière avec
lightroom 2 consorts mais en vidéo là il
va être aux fraises il va plus y arriver
et ça me paraît normal parce qu'à un
moment ça reste un smartphone donc voila
c'était pour vous montrer un peu ce
qu'on est capable de faire c'est
extrêmement factuel sait on y va on
shoote on regarde on montre c'est
vachement intéressant et une fois de
plus alors après ça dépend ce que vous
avez à faire des photos seins parce que
voyez des photos comme ça même si elles
sont sympas va venir autres aux hommes
et les imprimés on peut mais sur les
tout petits formats parce qu'à un moment
la qualité va se dégrader mais malgré
tout je reconnais que c'est extrêmement
bluffant et qui est un très très beau
travail fait que ce soit au niveau
matériel et au niveau logiciels
algorithmiques par samsung là dessus
alors le samsung galaxy s ii ultra on en
reparle très bientôt parce que enfin je
vais vous dévoiler mon test complet
parce que là je vous ai montré quelques
photos qu'on a fait dans le cadre de
l'urbex mais j'en ai fait plein d'autres
un plein plein plein plein plein face et
quand j'étais à paris a remis j'ai plein
de choses à vous montrer donc ça va être
vachement cool et puis on se parle aussi
bien évidemment très très très
rapidement de samsung galaxy tab et
suite ultra parce qu'elle est aussi très
intéressante et c'est la première fois
qu'on va arriver à un modèle aussi grand
modèle ultra au niveau de la tablette et
samsun donc rester connecté abonnez vous
ce n'est pas déjà fait vous invite à
cliquer sur le petit bouton rouge si les
rouges si vous n'êtes pas abonné puis
surtout à actionner la cloche que vous
soyez abonné ou partenaires il faut être
abonné sinon ça marche pas actionner la
cloche pour notifier dès qu une
prochaine vidéo arrivera je vous
embrasse prenez soin de vous et à très
vite pour parler de samsung et de pas
notre jolie monnaie à bientôt 15 12 ans
[Musique]